[Music]
[Applause]
a couple of months ago I took a look at
the GTX 1660 and showed how it's a
killer 1080p graphics card Wow if you're
interested in checking that video out
I've placed a link to it in the cards up
here and in the video description when
reviewing a GPU most PC tech reviewers
will pair their graphics cards with the
most powerful CPUs on the market in
order to ensure the maximum performance
from the graphics card they're reviewing
I on the other hand decided to do things
a little differently because in my
opinion the vast majority of gamers out
there don't have systems with CPUs like
the 99 hundred K or the Rison 930 900 X
and the reason they shop in the 250
dollar and below GPU market is simply
because that's what they can afford in
my gtx 1660 video I wanted to show more
of a real-world scenario you know to
just kind of show what kind of
performance you can expect out of a
graphics card upgrade when you're a
gamer playing on a five or six hundred
dollar entry-level rig that fits into
your budget or if you're you know
playing on an older hand-me-down
computer from your parents or someone
else I chose to pair the 1660 with both
a Rison 720 700 X which isn't the
highest end CPU out there but it's
definitely on the higher end
to illustrate the maximum performance
the 1660 is capable of and then paired
it with an AMD a10 5800 K system I built
some years ago I found that the GTX 1660
is far too powerful a card to pair with
a CPU like the a 1050 100 K it was being
bottleneck by about 50% most of the time
in games that I tested and sometimes
more because the a10 CPU is just too
slow to really complement the
GTX 1660 which is what brings me to this
video the rx 570 has the reputation of
being the best bang for the buck
graphics card at this point in time it's
capable of running most any game out
there at 1080p at or above 60fps with
the graphical settings cranked up pretty
darn high
most modern triple-a titles it can't
quite do max settings and still maintain
60fps but you can easily have them high
enough to still enjoy most all of the
eye candy and still maintain that 60fps
sweet spot the question that I plan to
answer in this video is how well does
the RX 570 pair with older slower CPUs
like my a 1050 800 K and hopefully give
you an idea of how the RX 570 may
perform in your rig should you choose to
upgrade to it as I kick this off I
should also mention the rx 570 is a
pretty decent overclocker I used MSI
Afterburner to squeeze just a little
more performance out of it I bumped the
core frequency up to 13 80 megahertz
from the stock's 1268 megahertz and the
memory up to 2,000 megahertz from 1750
in most of my games this gave me an
increased frame rate between 5 and 10
FPS but in Doom I saw an astounding 20
fps uplift in the Vulcan API
okay - build on way too long here let's
get to the games due to its continued
popularity the first game on our list is
fortnight when pairing it with my Rison
720 700 X I was able to maintain over 60
FPS at all times with all settings on
Epic except I did have to turn shadows
down to high as you can see here at the
beginning of the match our framerate is
very good as I run around looting and
harvesting materials this particular
area of the map must be more GPU
intensive or something because this is
where I experienced my lowest frame rate
of the entire match midway through my
framerate was in the
and even got above a hundred FPS at
times one moment that kind of surprised
me how high my framerate got was during
this sequence here when I have two other
players trying to eliminate me and
luckily build my way out of there by the
end of the match my framerate was still
in the 80s and 90s sure that probably
has a lot to do with where I was at on
the map too
but needless to say the RX 570 handled
itself very well in fortnight with my
2700 X when pairing the 570 with my 810
5800 K however things looked quite a bit
differently at the beginning of the game
my framerate was still above 60 fps
which was awesome but you'll now notice
that the GPU utilization percentage is
lower and than it was before when paired
with the 2700 X that was at a hundred
percent pretty much the entire time
with the a-10 however it's usually
somewhere between 60 and 80 percent with
the GPU not being fully utilized this of
course affects our frame rate by mid
game the frame rate is all over the
place ranging from the 40s to the 60s
with occasional drops into the 20s and
30s when these really massive drops
happen you can see that our CPU
utilization is way up this simply means
the a-10 is working as hard as it can
but it just can't keep up with the rx
570 if you've heard of CPU bottlenecking
but aren't sure what it is this is it
when paired with a more powerful CPU the
RX 570 has no problem
running at a very high frame rate all of
the time however when you pair it with a
CPU like the a-10 5800 K the slow
performance of that CPU really limits
the 570s performance lately I've really
been enjoying playing the division and
recently picked up the division 2 also
but haven't started it yet so even
though it's a few years old I'm using
the first division game for this video
in the division I was able to run on the
high preset and consistently stay above
60 fps at 1080p when paired with my
Rison 720 700 X when you're outside in
this game is when you see the biggest
hit in
in this particular section that I
captured the frame rate stays above 70
FPS most of the time but in this game
there are areas where there are a lot of
buildings and debris and other detailed
stuff on screen at the same time and
it'll drop your frame rate down into the
60s with some very brief dips into the
mid to high 50s on the high preset for
the most part though the 5 70 runs this
game way over 60 fps when you're inside
buildings and stuff the frame rate jumps
up pretty significantly into the 90s and
even over a hundred fps a lot of the
time of the six games I tested the
division is the game the a10 struggled
with the most when I was inside of
buildings and stuff the framerate seemed
quite good in the 70s and 80s but when I
went outside the frame rate would drop
into the 40s and 50s and in some areas
even down into the 30s CPU usage was
hegh dat a hundred percent pretty much
all the time when I played the division
so just like we saw in fortnight the
a-10 just couldn't feed info to the 570
fast enough
moving on to shadow of the Tomb Raider
when paired with my a 10 system I got a
bit of a mixed bag of performance in
many areas of the game GPU usage was
between 70 and 80 percent which gave us
a frame rate in the 40s and 50s even in
some of the larger outdoor areas however
in an area of the game called the hidden
city we encountered a pretty huge CPU
bottleneck this area is much larger than
any of the other areas in the game I've
played so far and had a lot of NPCs and
stuff running around and whatnot here
CPU usage was of course pegged at 100%
and the GPU usage dropped down to
between 40 and 50 percent which then
just tanked the frame rate into the 20s
this made things feel pretty choppy this
is by far the worst performance I saw in
this game like I already mentioned in
most areas the frame rate was in the 40s
and 50s
would even move above 60fps depending on
what all was going on this much better
frame rate is what I experienced when
Lara was inside exploring tombs and even
in many outdoor areas with tomb raider
being more of an adventure slash puzzle
game thankfully you don't really need a
super high frame rate to enjoy other
than the times the frame rate dropped
into the 20s playing shadow of the Tomb
Raider on the a-10 was actually quite
enjoyable when switching over to the
2700 X on the other hand we find out
what the rx 570 is actually capable of
60 FPS at high settings is no problem at
all
on average I saw about a 20 FPS uplift
in this game when switching to the more
powerful 2700 X CPU another one of our
top performers was 2016's doom I like
using this game in videos like this
because well it's one of the few games I
know of that uses the Vulcan API and
it's also one of those games that looks
really good is loads of fun to play and
runs well even on lore and hardware
using the Vulcan API at TEP on ultra
settings the RX 570 crushed this game
when paired with my 2700 X it ran well
over a hundred FPS even in rooms filled
with enemies trying to turn me into a
permanent resident of hell even when
paired with the a-10 it never fell below
60fps in fact unless there was a crap
ton of enemies on screen it ran anywhere
between eighty and a hundred fps
this may be just my opinion but far cry
5 is a perfect game to showcase how the
RX 570 is the current 1080p 60fps value
King when paired with my Rison 720 700 X
I was able to run far cry 5 on ultra
settings and maintain an almost constant
60 FPS or higher at 1080p it did
occasionally drop into the 50s but
always came back up over 60 almost
immediately it impressed the heck out of
me that a 160 issue dollar graphics card
can run this game that well at that kind
of detail like Tomb Raider when paired
with the a 1050 800 K our frame rate
decreased by about 20 fps at the same
resolution and settings while I feel the
game is still playable at this frame
rate I'm sure there are others out there
that would disagree strongly with that
opinion but this is my video so mine is
really the only opinion that matters
right now
the final game I tested for this video
is Ghost Recon wildlands once again when
paired with the 2700 X the power of the
arcs 570 really impressed me wildlands
is known for being a very demanding
title and the 570 was able to handle the
very high preset at 1080p very well I
had a couple times where the framerate
dipped into the 50s but for the most
part it stayed well above 60 fps I only
wish the same could be said when paired
with the a 1050 800 K performance wasn't
quite cut in half when using the a-10
but there were times it got pretty close
like I experienced in Far Cry and Tomb
Raider the framerate was often 20 or
more FPS lower in wild lands and while I
could still play the game okay
at 30 and 40 FPS it's tough to do so
knowing the RX 570 is capable of much
better than that now I do recognize that
many of you out there watching this
video trying to decide if the RX 570 is
worth spending your money on don't have
either of the CPUs I used in this video
the idea that I'm going for is showing
the two extremes in hopes that your CPUs
performance is somewhere between these
two the 1850 100k is on par performance
wise with five and six-year-old eye 3s
and is also pretty close to an FX 6100
if you have an i3 from within the last
three or four years or an i5 or i7 from
within the last five years I think
you'll be able to get much closer to the
maximum performance of the RX 570 on the
AMD side of things to get the best
performance out of the RX 570 you'll
need to have an FX 8313 CPU just a quick
disclaimer I don't have any of this
hardware to test so I feel I should
mention that I'm basing this
recommendation on information that I've
found online as well as in other videos
on YouTube
well it's about time I wrap this video
up please hit the like button if this
video helped you with your decision to
purchase an RX 570 or if you simply
enjoyed watching it
share it with your friends and subscribe
to my channel if you are not already and
if you would like to help support what I
do on my channel please check out my
Amazon store at the link in the video
description where you can purchase an RX
570 like the one I used for this video
as well as other products I have
featured in past videos thank you so so
much for watching I hope you have a
fantastic day and I look forward to
hanging out again in another video we'll
catch you later
[Music]
you